jetzt stehen schon ein paar wichtige
garten aufgaben auf der agenda damit wir
dafür sorgen können dass das ein richtig
gutes gartenjahr welt und wir fangen an
mit dem schnitt der obstbäume und der
beerensträucher das kann man jetzt im
januar gut machen wir machen das
manchmal auch erst im februar ist jetzt
kein stress das geht auch im märz noch
es ist nur wichtig dass man sich einmal
im jahr auch ein bisschen um die
mehrjährigen pflanzen kümmert
beziehungsweise um die obst gewächse und
das belohnten die dann mit einer reichen
sie ist die ernte deswegen macht es auf
jeden fall ich habe schon mal zwei
videos gemacht zum wachwerden schneiden
und zum johannisbeeren schneiden die
findet ihr unten in der video
beschreibung über obstbäume habe ich
noch nichts gemacht aber da gibt es auch
jemanden der das viel besser kann
nämlich der dominique er hat ein höchst
kanal jürgen den weil ich euch auch
unten in der video beschreibung wenn ihr
darüber mehr lernen wollt bleiben wir
mal kurz beim groups bevor wir uns
gleich um die gemüsepflanzen kümmern man
kann jetzt auch wunderbar obstbäume und
beerensträucher pflanzen es ist immer
gut so früh wie möglich die obstbäume
und beerensträucher zu pflanzen weil die
nämlich eine ganze weile brauchen bis
sie dann irgendwann ertrag abwerfen wenn
das erledigt ist schneller hat man dann
eben auch die erste obsternte der januar
ist auch eine tolle zeit um die beete
vorzubereiten war ja schon bei die
ersten ausfahrten anstehen das heißt ich
entfernen jetzt so langsam die alten
kohl strünke die noch im bett stehen und
harke mal durch und wenn du kommst aus
bringen willst dann ist jetzt auch eine
super zeit dafür ich bringe jetzt auch
urgesteins mail und vor allem pflanzen
kohle in meinem garten aus die kohle
bindet nochmal die nährstoffe so dass
die nicht ausgewaschen werden und
speichert wasser und so kann man den
boden jetzt noch mal vor der
gartensaison richtig schön aufpeppen
eine noch viel wichtigere aufgabe ist
den anbau plan zu erstellen und ich bin
eine große große verfechterin von einem
ausgeklügelten anbau planen weil man so
zum beispiel drei ernten statt einer
ernte in einem jahr von ein und
demselben beete einfahren kann wenn man
das einfach sehr gut plant und die beete
sehr gut ausnutzt man muss sich da auch
keine sorgen machen dass man den boden
zu viel abverlangt wenn der ständig
gemüse drauf wächst dass es im gegenteil
total gut für den boden wenn der immer
gewachsen ist und deswegen ist es jetzt
ganz wichtig sich einmal hinzusetzen und
ich bin das auch total die schöne garten
aufgabe ich hab damit tage zugebracht
dieses jahr und einfach mal zu überlegen
was man gerne essen möchte und wie man
das hinkriegt dass man rund ums jahr
ernten kann so dass man auch immer
wieder gemüse aus seht also salat sehe
ich zum beispiel jeden monat aus und
nicht nur einmal im frühling so dass wir
dann auch rund ums jahr enden können und
wenn euch das zu viel ist dann könnt ihr
euch gerne meinen kostenlosen pflanzplan
herunterladen den link packe ich euch
hier hin und in die video beschreibung
und den dann an euren garten anpassen
das steht auch mit bei was er macht wenn
ich jetzt zum beispiel einen blumenkohl
anbauen volt und der aber im plan drin
ist da könnt ihr dann noch kleine
anpassungen vornehmen und der rest steht
aber schon dass es ganz praktisch aber
ansonsten setzt euch hin mit einer tasse
tee und fangt an euch auszumalen wie
dieser wunderschöne garten im sommer
aussehen soll und ich sag euch das macht
süchtig und wenn der anbau plan dann
steht dann geht's an den saatgut kauft
dann schaut ihr welche saatgut tütchen
vielleicht leer geworden sind und guckt
ob ihr vielleicht neue sorten anbauen
wollt jetzt flattern ja auch überall die
saatgut kataloge ins haus und man kann
sich inspirieren lassen ein bisschen
weiter träumen paar bunte karotten
anbauen vielleicht stadt orange farbene
und ein paar neue tomatensorten
ausprobieren und dann schickt eure
saatgut bestellungen raus damit die dann
auch rechtzeitig da sind wenn es richtig
losgehen werden jetzt hab ich doch noch
in den obst tipp also wenn ihr zum
beispiel beerensträucher habt ihr euch
so richtig gut schmecken oder eure
nachbarn haben welche und ihr habt noch
selber noch gar keine dann könnt ihr
jetzt stecklinge von denen nehmen da
schneidet ihr einfach ungefähr so lange
ein stückchen ab auch wenn er jetzt ich
mache das eigentlich immer ich ziehe
immer so ein bisschen
ich mach das wenn ich meine
beerensträucher sowieso schneide und
dann bewusste ich die besten stöckchen
von denen in einfach im beet ich denke
die einfach so in die erde man kann die
auch erstmals zu hause in den wasserglas
stellen das funktioniert auch gut und
sie dann einen pflanzen oder sie unter
planzen da gibt es unterschiedliche
möglichkeiten so könnt ihr dann zum
beispiel aus einem leckeren beeren
strauch gleich fünf oder sechs machen
und das ist ziemlich cool deswegen wenn
ihr platz hat für beerensträucher dann
warum ich über nachwuchs nachdenken dann
ist es natürlich total wichtig dass
jetzt aufpasst wann denn frost
angekündigt ist damit ihr eure
gemüsepflanzen schützen können weil es
gibt ja manche sowie der rosenkohl und
der lauch die stecken das easy werk auch
wenn es mal richtig kalt wird aber zum
beispiel der kohlrabi oder auch salat
die müssen ein bisschen besser geschützt
werden müssen im zb einen fleece
eingemummelt werden oder gibt ganz viele
unterschiedliche möglichkeiten man kann
auch mini tunnels aufbauen und deswegen
ist es ganz klug jetzt einfach ein
bisschen den wetterbericht im auge zu
behalten und zu schauen wann es denn
richtig keit wird damit die dann auf
eure pflänzchen aufpassen könnt und
nächste tipp wenn es dann richtig kalt
ist dann lass die finger von euren
pflanzen die möchten dann nicht so gerne
angefasst werden und auch nicht geerntet
werden weil die dann nämlich schaden
nehmen können wenn ihr die aber einfach
so im beet auftauen lässt dann kann die
pflanze sich von selber wieder erholen
von diesem frost und wächst einfach
munter weiter nur in diesem
eingefrorenen zustand sind die pflanzen
eben total empfindlich und deswegen
sollte man die da ganz in ruhe lassen
und auch wenn frost angekündigt ist
einmal vorher richtig viel ernten dem
wochen einen kaufen karten machen so
dass man über die zeit auch nicht mehr
ernten muss jetzt kann man auch schon
einige aussagen machen wenn du wissen
willst welche das sind dann schaue gerne
da drüben vorbei ansonsten abonnieren
gerne den kanal weil ich jetzt jeden
monat 1 von diesen garten aufgaben
videos kleine und dann bist du immer up
to date was gerade draußen ansteht und
dann geh raus und macht die welt ein
bisschen grüner und wir sehen uns am
samstag um 10 für ein neues video thies